[Music]
hi my name is Roman Nurik from the
Android team at Google and in today's
design by I'd like to talk to you about
how screen pixel density affects your
workflow as an Android app designer
let's take a look so the first thing to
understand is that Android devices come
in all shapes and sizes and the screens
on these devices have different pixel
densities and this number is measured in
dots per inch or dpi and these pixel
densities simply say you know in a given
square say inch of space on the screen
how many pixels will fit in and this
determines very much the kind of the
level of crispness that you're going to
see graphics and text and things like
that on that screen so in this example
here a couple of different dpi values
possible dpi values and how text in this
case the letter a would be rendered on
those screens you'll notice that on the
higher density screens the letter A is
rendered in a much more crisp a much
more almost correct representation of
the letter A than on the medium density
screen on the left now as a designer
these pixel densities like 165 234 and
so on
could be very cumbersome to work with so
fortunately Android has created
something called logical pixel densities
or buckets of densities that the real
densities would fall into to simplify
things and so here on screen you see a
couple of the key the most important
logical densities that you as a designer
would have to work with so something
like if a real device had 165 dpi screen
that would be mapped down to 160 dpi and
then everything that you would do from
that point on you wouldn't have to worry
about the 165 number you simply think
about oh this screen I will treat as a
160 dpi screen and 160 dpi is a special
value it's something called the baseline
density on Android wear everything and
specifically the the density independent
pixel units we'll talk about in a second
where everything is
based on this baseline density so that's
160 dpi at the other foreigner of the
spectrum currently the highest number
the highest logical density is extra
extra high DPI or xxhdpi which is 480
dots per inch and so there are four
specific densities between 160 and 480
that you should really be aware of
that's 160 240 320 and 480 now there are
a couple that are not listed here
there's a ldpi at 120 and TV DPI at 213
but those are less common and you
generally don't need to worry about
those so now that we understand density
let's now talk about something that's
critical to designing for Android and
that's the density independent pixel
unit now density independent pixel units
which are sometimes abbreviated as DP or
di P sometimes referred to as dips in
conversation they're a virtual pixel
unit and they're equivalent to one
physical pixel that's one physical pixel
on the screen on an mdpi or 160 dpi
screen and now if you have you know a
single density independent pixel on a
mdpi screen that's one physical pixel
but if you're on a larger screen let's
say an xhdpi screen it's actually four
pixels two across and two down so why do
we use density independent pixels well
the reason for that is that we want to
make sure that when we create layouts
and overall kind of define the user
interface for our application we want to
make sure that the UI elements remain
the same physical size approximately
across devices with different densities
we don't want to have to specify for
each individual density what the sizes
of our UI elements should be so let's
look at an example so here we have 200
dips and again dip units or DP units
keep things roughly the same physical
size across devices so we have 200 DP
units
we have let's say this this wide purple
rectangle that's spanning across a
couple of devices now on an mdpi device
like the tablet you see here 200 dps
will actually result in something that
is 200 pixels tall so again 1 DP is 1
pixel at at mdpi now on an xhdpi device
like this like this nexus 4 here the 200
dps will actually become 400 pixels tall
and this is actually built in behavior
if you specify that something should be
200 DP it'll be the same physical size
on different devices now one interesting
thing about DP units is that since
they're the same physical size across
devices we can start representing
physical objects in terms of DPS so for
example the fingertip the human
fingertip is about 50 DPS wide now what
that means is that when you are sizing
your buttons and other UI elements you
want to make sure that things don't get
too small small enough to touch you know
make sure that they're about the size of
a human fingertip so that a regular
person could comfortably press that
button without making too many mistakes
so let's look at some math that will
help us get comfortable with converting
between pixels and DP units now here's
the only real formula you need to solve
for one of the variables you simply plug
in the other two so let's look at some
examples so here's the the definition of
DPS one pixel is one dip or one dip is
one pixel at 160 dpi easy enough now on
a 320 dpi screen one dip is actually 2
pixels 2 pixels across and 2 pixels down
so let's actually put this equation in
practice and look at a quick exercise
so how big is the 2013 Nexus 7 screen in
density-independent pixels now the
information we have is that we know that
the screen is seven inches across
diagonally we know that it's an xhdpi
screen meaning it's a 320 dpi screen and
we also know that the screen resolution
is 1920 by 1200 pixels and so the first
thing you may want to ask yourself is
you know what information here is
necessary now the fact that it's a 7
inch screen here is not actually
necessary to calculate the number of
density-independent pixels we don't
actually need a diagonal screen size if
we have the number of pixels and the
density so if you look at the formula
from before you'll notice that the ratio
between xhdpi and mdpi is 2 to 1 so to
convert from pixels to DP units on an
xhdpi device you simply divide by 2 and
so the answer here is 1920 divided by 2
by 1200 divided by 2 or simply 960 by
600 density independent pixels so you
may be asking what's the point of this
calculation well the reason is that
density independent pixels better
capture device physical screen size
pixels could be the same across devices
of different screen sizes for example
you can have a medium density tablet at
1280 by 800 pixels and an extra high
density phone at 1280 by 720 pixels and
their screen resolutions and pixels are
almost the same but that same phone will
actually have a much smaller screen
resolution when looked at in terms of
density independent pixels and so
density independent pixels better
capture that so with that let's move on
to some quick tips before we sign off so
first remember to design inspect all of
your layouts in terms of arrangement of
UI elements the sizes of elements the
positions of elements make sure to spec
that all out in deep
units it's gonna make it a lot easier
for your developers to implement things
correctly ii remember that because there
are a number of different densities for
optimal crispness of assets you want to
make sure that you provide those graphic
assets those PNG files in all the
different densities so here's an example
of a share icon you want to make sure
that you're providing it in four
different densities if possible an
xxhdpi all the way down to mdpi and to
do again the calculation for the sizes
of these things you simply use the
formula that we used before so if we
know that we want to have a thirty-two
DP square icon we'll know that on an
xxhdpi device the asset you need for
that should be 96 by 96 pixels so that's
it on today's design byte on how screen
density and specifically density
independent pixels should affect your
workflow as a designer stay tuned for
more InDesign bytes on how to put this
into practice in tools like Photoshop
and illustrator and so on thanks